[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs on
commence avec le sommaire de ce numéro
ce dimanche et la journée portes
ouvertes de la ferme de grignon des jeux
des balades en tracteur ou en poney et
des démonstrations de différents métiers
de la ferme
nous recevrons le directeur dominique
tristan qu'on nous parlait du programme
la troupe art magic de montigny le
bretonneux présente sa comédie musicale
double fera son spectacle coloré et
moderne
à découvrir samedi soir à la ferme du
manet maurepas sera en fête samedi
également l'association nord pas d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui organise sa
traditionnelle fête du village
le point avec mes amis pocket sur les
animations proposées peinture mobilier
vintage bijoux lampes les créations
d'une dizaine d'artistes du club des
huit sont à découvrir tout le week end
une exposition mais pas seulement le
collectif fera découvrir ses ateliers et
le public pourra échanger avec les
artistes
rendez-vous à l'aérodrome de saint cyr
l'école dès le vendredi 9 juin 18h
jusqu'à dimanche
parmi les oeuvres exposées les pièces
d'arnaud rougier il réalise des langues
en pièces d'avion récupérer c'est aussi
le président de l'association
en l'écoutant je suis créateur passionné
d'objets d'art je fais ça par passion je
créé principalement des lampes et du
mobilier à partir de matériaux de
récupération pièces d'avion pièces de
bateaux bois métal
ces trois des assemblages assez
harmonieux c'est un moment d'échangé où
on présente et nous vendons nos
créations puisqu'il faut quand même les
vendre c'est surtout les présenter au
public et faire découvrir un pot cet
espace qui bénéficie d'un grand
potentiel et partez pour un tour du
monde en musique à villepreux la
médiathèque le nautilus accueille
jusqu'au 22 juin une exposition
consacrée aux instruments de musique du
monde entier elle est mise en place avec
l'association a dit mme les écoles de
musique de la verrière et villepreux
dans le cadre de cette exposition
deux concerts sont organisés ce week end
samedi au nautilus avec l'école de
musique de villepreux et dimanche en
compagnie du haïdouti orkestar au
théâtre de villepreux la directrice de
l'école de musique de villepreux nous en
dit plus sur ces deux concerts samedi ce
sont donc les musiques du monde donc il
ya un morceau orientales un morceau des
balkans des morceaux également européens
notamment aux landais voilà où du nord
de l'europe
un morceau de la galice un de deux
traditions celtes et puis dimanche c'est
principalement autour des balkans la
musique orientale autour des balkans
voilà
[Musique]
et ce dimanche la ferme de grignon sera
en fait toute la journée elle organise
sa traditionnelle journée portes
ouvertes
de nombreuses animations seront à
découvrir avec nous le directeur de la
ferme dominique tristan bonjour bonjour
alors dites-nous qu'est ce qui nous
attend dimanche comme j'ai dit de
nombreuses animations qu'est ce qu'il y
aura alors déjà le beau temps voilà ces
experts ont été bien théo et à l'air
d'être au beau fixe pour ce week-end
donc c'est très bien donc plein
d'animations pour ceux qui connaissent
un petit peu la ferme c'est vrai qu'on
est ouvert au public toute l'année par
contre le regard du petit peu l'accent
sur l'accueil pour pouvoir communiquer
plus dans le détail sur nos métiers sur
ce que l'on fait et on en profite pour
revenir des collègues producteurs
fermiers d'autres personnes en lien
qu'agriculture qui viennent rennes aussi
communiquer sur leur métier et ce qu'ils
font autour de l'agriculture
tu auras des échanges de produits mais
également des animations des jeux et des
balades et des balades voilà donc en
poney vous l'avez dit balades en
tracteur qui est toujours un grand
moment notamment pour les enfants on
voit les yeux qui s'écarquillent
lorsqu'on les prend avec nous dans la
cabine cette impression voilà tout à
fait puis aussi un moment où on peut
communiquer sur notre façon de produire
avec toute évolution que l'on a
actuellement dans la nature sur le
numérique sur les capteurs sur les
satellites sur toutes les sauces et les
choses là qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
portée et que l'on met à profit pour
cultiver autrement et produire toujours
nous et vous avez dit l'idée c'est de
communiquer il y aura également des
démonstrations de différents métiers de
la ferme et notamment des démonstrations
de chiens de troupeaux ouais tout à fait
on a la foi nous des chiens pour
l'élevage bovin et pour l'élevage ovin
là on fait intervenir un collègue
professionnels dresseur qui vient
expliquer comme on dresse un chien la
relation entre l'homme et l'animal
finalement et comment on peut tirer
profit de cette relation pour faciliter
notre vie et aussi à avoir une autre
approche de l'élevage donc c'est
toujours intéressant et aussi un peu
bleus font de voir comment on peut
travailler avec un chemin entre potes
c'est toujours impressionnant à voir on
connaît pas très bien ce métier surtout
pour les enfants même la balade en
tracteur c'est des choses qu'ils ont
peut-être pas l'habitude de voir tous
les judas fenêtre vous n'avez donc c'est
ben voilà c'est un moment où un peu
privilégié pour la ferme ça rendez vous
annuel assez important pour nous qui est
un moyen de communiquer avec les gens
qui nous connaissent qui viennent
régulièrement mais aussi les les autres
populations
on voit un peu moins sombre affaire et
justement vous l'avez dit c'est un
moment important pour vous notamment en
tant qu'agriculteur de faire découvrir
un peu le différents métiers votre
travail au quotidien comment comment ce
qu'on produit de la nourriture
simplement oui oui c'est vrai alors les
agriculteurs ont l'habitude d'avoir un
emploi du temps assez chargé on compare
souvent le temps de communiquer sur nos
métiers tout voir un peu la tête dans le
guidon et là bas ça permet aussi de
prendre un peu de recul de communiquer
de pouvoir répondre aux questions et
puis
d'avoir ce moment privilégié des changes
avec le monde agricole alors un mois
peut-être un peu plus générale sur la
ferme alors c'est un lieu qui existe
depuis vraiment de nombreuses années
c'était plus de 100 ans
je voulais s'est développée on est un
don qui lie à l'école d'agroparistech
maintenant qui est le jeu de plusieurs
fusions et le début de la ferme c'est
1826 avec l'école royale d'agriculture
qui se passait sur le campus de grignon
et donc à ce titre là on continue à
avoir des missions de service public
comme comme la communication que l'on va
faire
dimanche par vous et donc c'est un bon
voilà de communication qui prolonge
toutes ces actions de service public
combien d'animaux en centre votre ferme
qu'est ce qui alors on est deux à ces
gros troupeau il ya quasiment 200 vaches
laitières et puisqu'on est pdg nice donc
les vaches de remplacement quelque part
et 600 brebis allaitantes sur sur la
ferme ça fait pas mal à pas mal de monde
le groupe a nourri la vie à s'occuper
tout à fait et vous avez évolué
justement alors vous l'avez
depuis 1826 ans et ça que cela ferme
existe alors au fil des années ça a
beaucoup évolué notamment en faveur de
l'environnement
depuis 2006 vous êtes engagé dans un
projet pour réduire votre consommation
d'énergie vos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre c'est quelque chose d'important
pour vous d'évoluer dans la protection
de l'environnement
on voit alors quoi ce projet voilà il
est initié à plus de 10 ans maintenant
avec des réalisations concrètes
puisqu'on on a divisé diminué de 40 %
nos consommations d'énergie par litre de
lait produit par exemple
aujourd'hui on a un bilan carbone du
yaourt qui est deux fois inférieure un
yaourt industrielle classique donc et
des résultats tangibles
on a créé un méthaniseur que l'on pourra
d'ailleurs voir pendant la visite pour
produire du biogaz à partir de l'eau
tizié et ceux de gaz sert à chauffer
notre laiterie et et pour le process des
yaourts donc on est dans l'écologie
industrielle sur le site
et ça s'est traduit en plus par une
certification iso 14001 dès 2014 pour
prouver à tester qu'on est bien dans une
démarche d'amélioration continue sur les
questions environnementales et c'est un
secteur important c'est un créneau
important et c'est aussi un moyen de
communiquer positivement sur
l'agriculture on est quand même souvent
montré du doigt aujourd'hui sur les
impacts environnementaux de
l'agriculture et la réagit on répond
quelque part en donnant des illusions
des illustrations concrètes je vais y
arriver de réalisation avec des chiffres
mesurés précis et très rapidement un
petit chiffre parce que j'avais vu je
suis en tête mais j'ai plus le chiffre
exact combien de personnes nourrit
chaque année à près de 8000 personnes
nourries à travers tous les produits de
la ferme que ce soit les céréales les
yaourts la viande d'agneau la viande
bovine dans l'humide personne de nouri
et
aujourd'hui une quipe petite trentaine
de salariés sur tout le périmètre de la
ferme culturelle va j'ai transformation
puisque on produit de très beaux ya donc
une belle évolution de cette ferme en
tout cas merci dominique tristan d'être
venu sur notre plateau alors on le
rappelle pour découvrir la ferme de
grignon située à thiberville grignon
rendez vous dimanche au 11 juin dès 10
heures de nombreuses activités vous
attendent remercie beaucoup de mini
prisme mercier et le meurtre d'une jeune
femme commis à paris un fait divers à
première vue banale mais pas pour la
compagnie art magic la troupe présente
sa comédie musicale double face samedi
soir sur les planches de la ferme du
manet découverte dans ce reportage avec
les images de nicolas landry une bassine
d'energie sont une alliance la version
normalement laisser les choses telles
qu'elles derrière le corps d'une jeune
femme qui vient d'accoucher est retrouvé
sans vie chargé de l'enquète le
commissaire va devoir explorer tous les
milieux de la société
une intrigue qui mêle argent amour et
pouvoir il ya des questions de gémellité
de différence de niveau social de riches
de pauvres de de deux familles de
personnes seules deux personnes et
clandestine toutes sortes de milieux se
mélange au delà du meurtre au delà
au delà de l'enquète il ya le thème de
l'amour parce que toute cette histoire
existe parce que il y a une histoire
d'amour entre deux personnes et de cette
histoire d'amour découlent toutes ces
situations
une pièce décalée entre humour et
suspense double face et la troisième
comédie musicale écrite par l'uci itella
16 danseurs dix comédiens et parmi eux
cinq chanteurs se partagent la ceni dans
mon esprit tout ça va ensemble en fête
pour danser il faut une musique une
musique peut inspirer un mouvement est
une histoire inspire inspire des sons
des climats des situations qui peuvent
être traduites en dansant donc en
musique et ainsi de suite
j'adore la comédie musicale la troupe
art magic embarque les spectateurs
durant deux heures dans un tourbillon de
couleurs et de chorégraphies modernes
une explosion musicale
à découvrir sur la scène de la ferme du
manège
oui
[Musique]
et samedi sera festif une grande fête
est organisée
mélanie vous nous emmenez à maurepas à
la fête du village organisée par
l'association ment pas d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui alors cette association
organise de nombreuses fêtes sur la
commune notamment la veillée villageoise
qui a lieu en novembre ou en décembre
elle travaille aussi sur l'histoire et
la conservation du patrimoine ancien et
de la ville nouvelle
alors c'est une fête elle qui est
organisé depuis la création de
l'association en 1970 et depuis 17 ans
elle se déroule sur la place de la grand
mare alors c'est bien sûr rendez vous à
vivre en famille et de nombreuses
animations pour les enfants action
sculptera des ballons il y aura de la
pêche à la ligne il y aura du chamboule
tout et même un stand de maquillage mais
pas qu'eux qui nous avons aussi un bal
gratuit en fait pour tout les personnes
présentes dont ils peuvent danser sur la
place donc c'est surtout une fête
familiale et conviviale en fait tout au
tout les familles aiment se rassembler
d'ailleurs c'est une date qui notait
régulièrement sur les calendriers des
bords croisés et les festivités
commencent dès 18h 18h30 c'est bien ça
et ça se termine à minuit alors vous
pourrez aussi assister à une
démonstration de twirling bâton c'est
une discipline sportive et artistique
est originaire à des états unis il y
aura un bal qui sera animé par le groupe
dans son vin ty et durant cette soirée
lire aussi un repas proposé par
l'auberge le village alors un dîner
champêtre où vous pourrez notamment
déguster des grillades et des frites
une autre fête à ne pas manquer celle du
quartier de la clé saint-pierre à
elancourt celle ci débute à 14h30 et au
programme du maquillage un manège une
loterie et de la barbe à papa donc un
samedi très festif en prévision alors
que ce soit à maurepas où il encourt en
tout cas merci mélanie nous avoir parlé
de ces rendez vous et c'est maintenant
l'heure de trajan da
[Musique]
vendredi et samedi prochain le centre
alfred de vigny organise ses journées
portes ouvertes une cinquantaine
d'activités seront présentés de quoi
vous donner quelques idées pour vous
inscrire l'an prochain jusqu'au 18 juin
c'est la sixième édition du édition du
festival les yeux pleins d'étoilés à
saint-cyr-l'ecole une programmation de
films pour le jeune public et leurs
familles il y aura par exemple le dessin
animé anastasia où le film ma vie de
courgettes toutes les informations
auprès du cinéma les yeux d'elsa
c'est la fin de cette ut loisirs merci
de nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
et je vous souhaite un excellent week
end
m
vous